et pour ce club des territoires un débat
consacré aux homicides routiers internes
qui n'existent pas en droit ces
accidents mortels causés par des
chauffards sous l'emprise d'alcool ou de
stupéfiants faut-il renforcer la
législation durcir les peines crée ce
délit domicile routier comme le propose
Gérald Darmanin c'est le débat de ce
club et avec nous Isabelle Alleno
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes la maman d'Antoine laneno qui
a été tué le 8 mai dernier par un
chauffard ivre sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants vous nous en parlerez vous
avez créé avec le papa d'Antoine une
association pour venir en aide aux
familles de victimes d'accidents de la
route merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Laurent saumon sénateur les républicains
de la Somme bonjour Laurent saumon merci
d'être la hauteur d'une proposition de
loi pour une meilleure prévention des
violences routières et Vincent juillet
parade bonjour merci d'être là avocat
spécialiste en droit de dommages
corporel et vous aussi vous avez perdu
vous votre maman il y a 25 ans par la
faute d'un chauffard à Colisée on va
bien sûr parler de tout ça vos
témoignages d'abord Mathias on va voir
avec vous l'état actuel de la lég car ce
qu'on appelle homicide routier en
réalité dans son pas absolument rien en
fait pour le moment la qualification
domicile routine n'existe pas en droit
français lorsqu’une personne en état
débriété ou sous l'emprise de drogue
donne la mort à travers un accident de
la circulation et bien elle tombe sous
le régime de l'homicide involontaire je
vous en rappelle la définition dans la
loi l'homicide involontaire et le fait
de causer la mort d'autrui sans en avoir
l'intention il peut s'agir d'une
maladresse imprudence inattention
négligence ou manquement à une règle de
prudence ou de sécurité que prévoit la
loi et bien l'état actuel des choses
l'intentionnalité criminelle n'est
jamais retenue l'homicide involontaire
reste donc un délit et non pas un crime
l'auteur en cours lui une peine pouvant
aller jusqu'à 5 ans d'emprisonnement et
jusqu'à 75000 euros d'amende avec une
circonstance aggravante comme l'alcool
justement ou la consommation de
stupéfiants l'emprisonnement peut
atteindre 7 ans et la bande jusqu'à
100.000 euros avec plusieurs
circonstances aggravantes
peut aller jusqu'à 10 ans et 150000
euros d'amende merci beaucoup Mathias
pour ce point à l'heure actuelle
Isabelle Aleno on parle d'homicide
involontaire est-ce que c'est un mot qui
est difficile à entendre pour vous ce
mot involontaire ce mot il est
insupportable il est enfin vous pouvez
pas vous amuser vous vous perdez l'être
qui est le plus cher à votre cœur et et
on vous parle de
d'homicide involontaire et ça toutes les
on a reçu énormément de témoignages
suite à au lancement de l'association en
septembre dernier toutes les familles le
disent c'est un mot insupportable c'est
intolérable c'est on c'est inaudible en
fait on peut pas se dire
on va pas par moi je vais pas parler de
notre cas personnel parce qu'il y a une
procédure en cours donc ça serait un
petit peu difficile de de donner des
détails et autres mais on se dit que à
partir du moment où il y a quelqu'un qui
qui décide à un moment donné de prendre
le volant
il a bu il a consommé des stupéfiants il
y a obligatoirement une volonté de sa
part et il faut qu'il y ait vraiment une
prise de conscience que voilà quand on
quand on prend ce risque là on a pas
forcément conscience que
qu'effectivement on n'est pas on n'est
pas en état de conduire mais mais on met
la vie des dans des autres en danger la
voiture est un engin c'est une arme donc
quand on l'a quand on la met entre les
mains on va bien sûr en parler vous vous
entendez Laurent saumon le témoignage
d'Isabelle Aleno cette difficulté quand
on est victime famille de victimes dont
on tombe ce mot involontaire
complètement effectivement on le
qualifie domicile involontaire mais
comme l'a dit Madame Alléno c'est que
effectivement quelqu'un qui sait qu'il a
consommé de l'alcool ou de la drogue
c'est pertinemment ou qui n'a pas de
permis ou qui va rouler à une vitesse
excessive c'est pertinemment qu'il est
en infraction dès lors qu'il prend le
volant et par conséquent il doit être
questionner parce qu'il avait
connaissance des conséquences même si
elles sont involontaires de ce que ça
peut provoquer donc effectivement je
comprends que les familles et c'est
comme ça que j'ai été sensibilisé au
travers une famille sur Amiens ou on n'a
pas le sentiment que les juges prennent
en compte justement cette sentiment
cette ressenti des familles de la perte
d'un être et une double peine derrière
c'est à dire qu'il y a pas de
condamnation ferme de lorsque les
facteurs aggravants sont prouvés et on
va voir pardon effectivement le
témoignage de cette famille à un mot
avec vous d'abord Vincent gilet parade
involontaire ça veut dire évidemment que
les sanctions sont moindres et est-ce
qu'il y a aussi une différence entre ce
à quoi un chauffard pourrait être
condamné et ce à quoi il est condamné
réellement je pense que d'abord alors
aussi dur que ce soit il faut replacer
moins volontaire dans son contexte c'est
un terme juridique c'est une notion
juridique c'est le fait d'avoir
involontairement dans la volonté
d'atteindre un résultat précis pour
atteinte à la vie de à la vie d'autrui
et à mon sens en code pénal ce que
législateur a créé de plus représentatif
de ce que crée un chauffard c'est ce
qu'on appelle la mise en danger
délibérée de la vie d'autrui c'est
d'avoir mis en oeuvre tous les moyens en
connaissance de cause et d'être arrivé à
un résultat qui vous échappe après voilà
moi je suis avocat de victime j'ai perdu
ma mère je suis juriste donc j'explique
le terme d'inventaire mais je comprends
que pour les gens que je représente pour
vous pour toutes ces victimes le fait de
se dire que c'est à volontaire ça
sous-entend c'est de la [__] à pas de
chance et c'est pas de la patience voilà
c'est une accumulation prise de risque
en toute conscience de cause mais avec
il est vrai et ça le juriste obligé de
le reconnaître bah le fait que
contrairement à quelqu'un qui tue
volontairement un meurtrier au sens
humeur le chauffard va causer un
accident dont le résultat est donc
l'identité de la victime dont l'étendue
du dommage va totalement lui échapper
après pour répondre à votre question je
pense véritablement que l'autre chose
qui qui broie les victimes au-delà de la
qualification ce sont les grands hommes
de peine qui sont prononcés par rapport
à ce qui est encouru et ça c'est
inaudible également pour les familles
c'est le cas on va voir Isabelle Alleno
le témoignage Mathias c'est vous
inquiète aller rencontrer une famille
frappée par un drame dû à un chauffard
soyez absolument c'est la famille déjà
d'un
son fils Thibault qui je sais est en
contact avec vous monsieur le sénateur
qui depuis 2017 mène à bras le corps ce
combat puisqu'ils ont été touchés dans
leur chair avec le l'homicide de leur
frère Guillaume 21 ans qui était
étudiant médecine et qui rentrait un
soir à vélo avant d'être fauché par un
chauffard alcoolisé et on regarde ce
témoignage que vous êtes à l'air
cueillir
depuis bientôt 6 ans Thibault Desjardins
vite avec sa peine en septembre 2017 son
frère Guillaume 21 ans étudiant en
médecine rentre chez lui en vélo
lorsqu’un chauffard le fauche et lui ôte
la vie conducteur est rentré de soirée
il avait fait la tournée de plusieurs
bars et il a avoué avoir bu plusieurs
verres de whisky etc il était à 2 g
d'alcool donc il y a pas de doute sur le
fait qu'il était tout à fait conscient
qui devait pas conduire après deux
procès l'individu de 35 ans est condamné
à 3 ans de prison dont deux avec sursis
au final la peine sera aménagée en
quelques mois de détention à domicile
avec un bracelet électronique pour la
famille de Guillaume c'est l'incrédulité
moi j'ai plus été choqué par la réponse
judiciaire
que par la disparition de mon frère mon
père lui il arrivait pas à le vivre et
en fait cette absence de justice
pareil ça l'a enragé d'une certaine
manière face à vraiment choqué et un
moment j'ai du l'arrêter pour pas que
y avait un vrai sentiment de vengeance
et de
assez dur de se dire mais j'ai dû
arrêter mon père pour pas qu'il aille
faire du mal à cette personne quoi là
c'est vraiment une réaction viscérale
avant un constat implacable je pense que
ce qui est le plus choquant c'est de
savoir que c'est pas un cas exceptionnel
que c'est que c'est malheureusement ce
type de condamnation c'est tout à fait
banal c'est la norme on va pas en prison
quand tu quelqu'un
[Musique]
alors qu'on est libre au volant en
France et sa personne veut ça depuis
Thibault s'informe et traque ce qu'il
refuse personnellement d'appeler les
crimes de la route juste ici à la
hauteur de vélo là il y a une jeune
fille qui se fait écraser et par un
camion qui était sur la piste cyclable
et l'affaire a été classée sans suite
le jeune homme s'active il va à la
rencontre des députés et sénateurs de
son département la somme eux aussi sont
surpris des faibles taux de condamnation
ferme en moyenne une sur 10 pour des
faits de blessures involontaire par
conducteur en état d'ivresse ou sous
l'emprise de stupéfiant
c'était un étonnement
de choc
avec lesquels j'ai pu échanger
partisan même de droite ou gauche pour
faire évoluer la situation
Thibault va jusqu'à aider certains
d'entre eux à rédiger des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement ou même
apporter de l'aide pour la rédaction
d'une proposition de loi
arrêter c'est le recours systématique au
brasserie électronique et avoir plus de
choses comme la semi liberté les travaux
d'intérêt général à la prise en fer
voici ça peut être une une des réponses
voilà du travail avec des associations
obligé c'est chauffer ces conducteurs à
aller au contact des victimes à faire de
la prévention c'est des choses que la
justice aujourd'hui fait pas et qu'elle
pourrait faire car bien que blesser dans
sa chair Thibault Desjardins n'est pas
animé par un esprit de revanche il veut
selon lui que les peines et du sens pour
apporter des réponses aux victimes aux
condamnés mais aussi à la société
Isabelle Alleno il y a une phrase parmi
d'autres qui est très forte dans ce
reportage le frère de la victime dit
j'ai plus été choqué par la réponse
judiciaire que par la disparition de mon
frère est-ce que c'est une phrase que
vous comprenez est-ce que c'est un
sentiment que vous avez vous-même
ressenti on le ressent tous il y a on se
retrouve
en plus du choc de la sidération de ce
qu'on vit on se retrouve dans un dans un
monde qui qui a pas beaucoup d'humanité
en fait il y a pas beaucoup de prise de
considération de de voilà de la douleur
des familles de ce à quoi il se retrouve
confronté il y a beaucoup de solitude
donc oui il y a je comprends ça sa
réaction c'est
il y a beaucoup de sentiments
d'injustice
et de la part de la justice pardon de la
réponse judiciaire vous attendez à autre
chose vous moi franchement je
j'espère que nous on n'a pas encore de
date de d'audience pour l'instant
j'espère juste voilà que la justice va
faire son travail et que
la sentence qui sera enfin la peine qui
sera prononcée sera à la hauteur de la
gravité de des circonstances au moment
pardon le chauffeur qui a tué votre fils
a été remis en liberté le procès n'a pas
encore eu lieu donc toujours dans un cas
de présomption
est-ce que le fait qu'il ait été remis
en liberté ça a été difficile à vivre ça
a été très très difficile il y a eu
beaucoup de colère beaucoup
d'incompréhensions beaucoup de
sentiments d'injustice
on avait quand même été prévenus en
amont par par l'avocat qui nous qui nous
représente voilà mais voilà donc quand
la nouvelle tombe
voilà nous on se dit que notre fils bah
il est plus là et que la personne qui
est responsable elle est elle est dehors
et c'est un sentiment qui est partagé
par toutes les familles il y a la la
solitude l'incompréhension c'est
vraiment des choses qui mais qui
reviennent sans cesse dans les
témoignages qu'on reçoit et c'est ce
qu'on nous on a vécu également on les
entendez c'était maillage leur ont
souvent vu qu'il y avait évidemment
travaillé sur ce sujet oui c'est
véritablement une double peine la peine
déjà de perdre effectivement un être
cher le plus cher et puis la deuxième
c'est quand la justice se passe elle le
pas elle passe d'une manière un peu
j'allais dire
fluide et sans tenir compte justement de
la douleur que ça a pu provoquer chez
les chez les familles et la gravité des
faits au moment des faits c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a même pas une incarcération
préventive alors qu'on sait pertinemment
qu'il y avait de l'alcool qui avait de
la drogue et qui avait par le fait de
prendre son volant de sans avoir
l'intention de donner la mort néanmoins
de de savoir qu'on était conscient qu'on
prenait le volant dans des circonstances
qui étaient aggravantes et que par
conséquent il devrait y avoir une peine
plus ferme dès lors que c'est justement
pas un crime c'est là où il y a la
différence entre crime et délit un crime
il y aurait une incarcération j'allais
dire préventive le temps d'une
instruction qui est d'ailleurs trop
longue comme on le signal c'est qu'entre
le moment des faits le moment où ça
passe en justice le délai est tellement
long qu'il y a une certaine dilution
j'allais dire des faits ou de la gravité
des faits et que les juges sont plus ont
plus de mensuétude finalement pour les
les
responsables de ces de ces crimes que de
des familles qui sont touchées parce que
on a du mal à incarner pourquoi il y a
vous dites il y a plus de mensuétude
parce que alors j'ai rencontré quel est
le je ne dirais pas qu'il y a un manque
d'empathie parce qu'au contraire je
dirais les juges ont plutôt tendance
aujourd'hui à laisser s'exprimer
davantage les familles qu'elles ne le
faisait par le passé par contre
effectivement elles vont vous dire que à
quoi sert-il de pénaliser deux familles
parce que justement j'allais dire le
responsable peut avoir aussi une famille
on demande pas forcément une
incarcération pour une incarcération on
demande une privation de liberté pour
que les gens prennent conscience
véritablement de la gravité des faits
qu'ils ont commis c'est à dire que ça
peut être une privation de liberté les
gens vont travailler dans la journée
pour nourrir leurs familles mais le soir
ils ont une privation de liberté ils
peuvent pas regarder la télévision ils
peuvent va regarder les séries TV
peuvent pas être avec leurs enfants pour
qu'ils comprennent que les familles eux
ont perdu un être cher et sont privés in
fit définitivement j'irai de la de la
rencontre avec leur famille aujourd'hui
c'est ce n'est pas ça et le deuxième cas
c'est effectivement qu'on dit que les
prisons sont surchargées et que par
conséquent va pas donner des peines en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on entend c'est une
des causes que l'on peut donner c'est
l'urgences surchargé à quoi sert-il de
d'emprisonner pour 4 5 6 10 mois ou deux
ans quelqu'un qui a fait ce genre de
fait or je pense que effectivement la
loi prévoit des peines les peines
doivent être effectives elles doivent
être prononcées dans un délai
raisonnable et elles doivent être
suffisamment fort pour que les gens
prennent conscience de la gravité des
faits pourquoi ce n'est pas le cas
parce que si vous voulez je pense que
contrairement à aux autres types de
délinquance que que voit passer les
magistrats devant les chambres
correctionnelles que ce soit le vol le
trafic de drogue les violences vont
volontaires même les violences
conjugales
il y a derrière le responsable
d'accident de la circulation une telle
variété vous avez des jeunes vous avez
des moins jeunes et des hommes des
femmes des gens qui sont parfaitement
insérés par ailleurs et que donc il y a
toujours vu que la peine elle est fixée
en fonction des faits mais de la
personnalité vous avez toujours
l'impression que vous avez jugé
quelqu'un de normal et que donc vous
l'entendez à réquisition d'entre nous
c'est ça
peut-être aussi magistrat et donc il y a
une certaine
moi peut-être maintenant mais durant
très longtemps je pense que on avait
plus tendance à s'identifier à l'auteur
poursuivi qu'à la famille de la victime
qui venait dans ces tribunaux surcharger
et toute sa peine qu'on combler un peu
tout le monde bon
les choses changent quand même mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui encore
moi dès le stade des réquisitions
parfois j'ai j'ai les points qui suivent
les risques quand j'entends que on est
assez gêné de requérir une peine dans un
cas pareil où vous avez certains
résultats qui est indicible mais vous
avez par ailleurs un acte à la base qui
est une faute que qui n'est pas bien
mais qu'on peut tous commettre un jour
et que donc il faut faire la part des
choses et qu'il faut prononcer une peine
sévère et que quand le type est en cours
et 5 ans on requiert un an dont 8 mois 8
mois avec sursis et on oublie dans ce
raisonnement basé sur l'in volontaire
que le législateur l'a déjà pris en
considération quand il a fixé le grand
homme des peines encouru et donc ça ça
me pose problème et je pense également
que ce qui choque beaucoup les familles
c'est quand vous avez une peine ferme
qui est prononcée moi en tout cas moi
j'avais vécu et ton gamin quand j'ai pas
eu ma mère vous avez une peine ferme qui
est prononcée et vous avez le condamné
qui sera à côté de vous côte à côte de
la salle d'audience et vous avez quand
même un outil qui est très peu utilisé
par les magistrats qui pourraient être
ne serait-ce que symbolique mais qui
pourrait les familles on dirait beaucoup
c'est le mandat de dépôt à l'audience
vous avez une peine de prise en ferme
qui est prononcé même de quelques mois
elle est mise à exécution le toujours
même et ça je pense que c'est important
parce que ce que moi je plaise souvent
devant les magistrats c'est que certes
et vous l'avez dit Monsieur setter la
sanction doit avoir un sens pour
l'auteur mais les magistrats ne doivent
jamais oublier la justice ne jamais
oublier qu'elle a un rôle de régulateur
social et c'est qu'au travers des peines
quel prononce elle donne le signal de ce
qui est grave de ce qui n'est pas de ce
qui est acceptable de ce qui n'est pas
c'est ce qu'on a aussi entendu dans le
reportage aujourd'hui on ne va pas en
prison qu'on tue quelqu'un qu'on est
ivre au volant en France c'est ça aussi
qui est difficile à accepter oui parce
que on se dit il y a une faute enfin moi
c'est ce que j'ai enseigné à mes enfants
à partir du moment où on fait une bêtise
bah il y a une punition derrière donc
c'est c'est
je pense que c'est pour ça que vous
disiez les familles ne comprennent pas
voilà elles ont elles ont perdu ce qui
était l'être le plus cher au monde et
derrière ben le responsable
reste très peu enfin il y a des peines
qui sont quand même très légères parce
on en cours jusqu'à 10 ans de prison
pour pour ses délits à partir du moment
où il y a deux circonstances à gravantes
si j'ai je dis pas de bêtises mais c'est
très très rare que 10 ans soit prononcé
là
je crois que là il y a le TGI de d'Alès
qui a prononcé 10 ans mais c'est mais
c'est très récent
et jamais et c'est vrai que quand vous
entendez les familles qui vous disent
bah et oui il a pris trois ans où il a
pris 4 ans c'est quand même la vie de
vos enfants qui est qui est qui a été
qui a été volé nous on prend un
perpétuité nous les familles moi je me
remettrai jamais de la disparition de
mon fils jamais donc c'est c'est
incompréhensible que derrière il y a pas
une
toute façon ça nous remet ça nous rendra
jamais nos enfants on en est bien
conscient mais mais ce qui est voilà ce
qu'on veut enfin je pense que toutes les
familles demandent c'est qu'à partir du
moment il y a une faute et en plus il y
a des circonstances aggravantes pour la
plupart donc la drog à l'école voilà qui
est une punition et qui soit à la
hauteur enfin que en tout cas la peine
prononcée soit la hauteur mais du coup
est-ce qu'il faut changer la loi ou
est-ce qu'il faut déjà appliquer la loi
existante et appliquer réellement les
peines qui sont encourus avant de
répondre à votre question je voudrais
compléter il y a une double tromperie
enfin il y a une tromperie c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait quand la peine est jugée il y
a une prison ferme qui est prononcée la
presse se fait écho de cette peine mais
pas du tout des aménagements qui vont
suivre derrière et donc le public à
l'impression que les peines sont
prononcés alors que les familles savent
que les peines ne sont pas prononcées et
surtout la partie civile comme on dit
les victimes sont hors du circuit
l'exécution de la peine si vous voulez
une fois que la paix est prononcée la
victime qui a été tolérée par le système
judiciaire jusque là elle n'est plus
informée elle est même plus informée de
l'exécution de la peine et là je pense
qu'il y a une réflexion législative à
mener sur quelle place on donne aux
victimes dont le circuit d'exécution de
la peine non pas forcément pour lui
donner un pouvoir quel qu'il soit mais
au moins un droit d'information qui
m'apparaît à tout le monde légitime et
si je peux me permettre moi le droit
d'information il faut Acquier que ça
soit dès le départ nous quand c'est
arrivé pour Antoine on ne savait pas il
avait été il était et il y a des
familles nous encore
via Yannick on a réussi à passer des
appels pour savoir où avait été emmené
en toile mais il y a des familles qui
mettent des fois des jours et des jours
à savoir simplement où est leur enfant
ça c'est
insupportable
on n'a pas les familles disent aussi
qu'il y a pas il y a pas d'informations
sur sur la procédure ils savent pas ce
qu'ils doivent faire comme démarche
voilà il y a un manque d'accompagnement
certains donc il y a l'information mais
il y a l'accompagnement aussi Qui est
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas là et qui et
qui manque aujourd'hui
c'est exactement vous le savez vous
l'avez vécu je à travers mes dossiers et
c'est que contrairement à ce qu'on a pu
voir dans les médias ces derniers mois
quand vous perdez votre femme votre
enfant la justice l'enquête polémique
est ouverte vous n'avez vous n'avez
aucune information quand la presse n'en
parle pas vous n'avez aucune information
même parfois quand vous êtes avocat les
enquêteurs refusent en se cachant
derrière elle serait l'enquête de vous
donner la moindre information après vous
avez un juge association qui est désigné
vous devez
on m'a dit faire des demandes d'audition
pour avoir accès au dossier
ensuite vous avez notamment les mesures
de remise en liberté dans le cadre de
l'instruction dont vous n'êtes pas
informé
si vous voulez la victime elle est on va
dire
tolérer
tout au long de l'enquête parce qu'il
faut jamais oublier que quand on la
qualifie de partie civile c'est
simplement pour dire qu'elle a le droit
de réparation elle a le droit à obtenir
réparation financière elle est
simplement tolérée pour ça
il faut améliorer tout ça en formation
l'accompagnement des victimes la
proposition de loi que j'ai déposée
effectivement elle est elle est pas pour
gérer surcharger les peines ou en tout
cas accentuer les peines elles existent
les lois existent on demande seulement
qu'elle soit appliquées et donc cette
proposition de loi elle vise pas non
plus à requalifier même si je comprends
qu'on voudrait le qualifier domicile
routière il est apparu plusieurs PPL sur
ce sujet qui ont toujours été retoqués
parce que c'est un homicide involontaire
en tout cas tel que c'est prévu
aujourd'hui qu'on ne veut pas le
qualifier comme crime donc on ne veut
pas le requalifier par contre on veut
que les peines soient effectives en tout
cas à minima c'est-à-dire qu'il y ait la
possibilité d'un aménagement de peine
parce qu'on ne peut pas obéirais la
faculté des juges de pouvoir adapter les
peines c'est son rôle en fonction des
circonstances en fonction des
personnalités mais pour autant qu'il y
ait un minimum gérer de la peine qui est
prononcé notamment quand c'est
l'emprisonnement ferme qui est une peine
minimum qui soit effectuée pour que les
gens aient davantage se rendre compte
davantage de la gravité des faits qu'ils
t'ont ils ont été la cause
vous parlez pardon le rangement de cette
création de d'appellation dans des lits
d'homicide routier c'est Gérald Darmanin
vous le demandez Isabelle elle est nous
on va évidemment parler avec vous mais
Gérald Darmanin a mis ça sur la table il
y a absolument suite à la faire Palmade
les pouvoirs publics par l'intermédiaire
de du ministre de l'intérieur ou annoncé
vouloir recalifier ce type de fait en
créant un délit à domicile routier alors
le ministre de l'Intérieur a également
souligné le mois dernier sa volonté de
voir les peines alourdies donc par
exemple que le retrait des 12 points du
permis soit systématique dans ces cas
contre seulement 6 points pour le moment
enfin le ministre de l'Intérieur a donné
pour consigne aux forces de l'ordre
d'augmenter aussi le nombre de contrôle
routier contre la drogue et l'alcool
pour passer à un million en 2023 contre
800 000 l'an dernier Isabelle allait
nous ce sont des bonnes pistes les
pistes ce qui s'est pas en général
Darmanin oui après tout je pense que il
faut que les il faut que la loi évolue
il faut que
que les choses changent il faut qu'il y
ait vraiment une réelle prise de
conscience
de la gravité des faits
pourquoi vous militez vous pour la
création de ce délits domicile routier
pour que ça soit nommé comme ça
parce que comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure le mot involontaire il est il
est insupportable insupportable donc
c'est aussi qui est vraiment une réelle
prise de conscience que
la voiture c'est c'est une arme et quand
on a un comportement qui n'est pas
adéquate
il faut qu'il y ait quelque chose qui
arrive derrière et
les familles elles les associations de
famille les familles elles le demandent
depuis des années cette création
domicile routier parce que c'est
primordial pour pour nous et c'est très
important c'est une pour une vraie vraie
enfin une vraie prise de conscience vous
l'entendez ça Laurent sûrement le
témoignage d'Isabelle Alleno le fait que
ça aiderait à la prise de conscience et
que ça mettrait fin un peu moins
volontaire qui n'est pas supportable oui
je le comprends je dis on l'a pas mis
dans notre tête
si je suis favorable mais pour l'instant
à chaque fois que ça a été tenté
j'allais dire et plusieurs fois avec
plusieurs PPL tentent députés que de
sénateur ça a toujours été refusé parce
qu'on considère encore une fois que le
fait de prendre le volant même avec des
facteurs aggravants c'est un acte
involontaire c'est un homicide
involontaire c'est effectivement
d'arriver à requalifier que le fait de
prendre le volant en ayant conscience
qu'on a consommé de l'alcool qu'on a
souvent de la drogue ou d'autres
compétences qui peuvent être aussi
aggravantes ou quand on fait un excès de
vitesse de la même manière on sait qu'on
fait quelque chose de délictueux est-ce
qu'on peut le qualifier en crime ça
travaille sur ce sujet est-ce que si ça
aboutit c'est quelque chose que vous
soutiendrez bien sûr des deux mains le
problème c'est qu'on l'a pas mis nous
parce qu'on voulait avancer déjà sur des
résultats tangibles immédiats
aujourd'hui une affaire médiatique plus
importante que les autres parce que ça
arrive tous les jours a permis de
remettre à la surface je dirais la
douleur des familles et donc la gravité
des faits que aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'intérieur comme le ministre de la
Justice en prennent compte parce que moi
j'avais questionné le ministre de la
justice il y a quelques temps il nous
disait mordicus que les prisons étaient
les sanctions étaient prononcées et
qu'elles étaient effectuées or seulement
10% j'irai des gens qui sont les
responsables de ces faits vont par la
passe par la case prison donc on voit
bien que ce n'était pas la réalité
dommage que ce soit je dirais quelqu'un
qui est
illustre entre guillemets qui soit
responsable pour que les choses arrivent
je pense que tout le monde mérite qu'on
soit pauvre ou qu'on soit riche qu'on
soit petit ou qu'on soit grand qu'on
prenne conscience je dirais de la
gravité des faits et de défendre les
familles quel que soit je dirais leur
statut vous parlez de l'affaire Palma
d'un Gérald Darmanin dit qu'il a
commencé à travailler sur le sujet avant
cette affaire et qu'il a demandé aux
forces de l'ordre de durcir les
contrôles routiers déjà depuis plusieurs
mois la création de ce délit domicile
routier Vincent Julie
perazzo je vais être parfaitement
honnête et je le dis en tant que d'abord
en tant que victime moi j'aime pas me
réfugier derrière ça parce que ça fait
25 ans et je pense que mais et surtout
en tant qu'avocat de victime je vais
vous avouer je suis
je comprends moi je j'ai vraiment je
comprends le message qui est porté j'ai
travaillé avec des associations sur la
réflexion autour de ce sujet je suis
assez dubitatif néanmoins je vais vous
dire pourquoi
parce que comme je vous l'ai dit le
résultat d'un accident il échappe à son
auteur et que je on pourra qualifier
domicile routier sans bouleverser les
peines en donnant une qualification
particulière à quelqu'un qui aura tué
mais si le hasard la chance ou la
malchance je ne sais pas fait que la
victime ne meurt pas mais fini tes
traplégique comme un de mes clients que
j'ai vu hier à cause de quelqu'un qui
était
ivre mort au volant
pourquoi est-ce que ma victime qui était
traplégique elle devrait en demeurer à
une qualification de blessures à
volontaire parce qu'on sera obligé de
maintenir cette qualification là
qu'est-ce qui fait que on devrait
hiérarchiser une qualification en
fonction de résultat qui n'a pas été
contrôlé par l'auteur parce que vous
savez pour la victime qui est lourdement
handicapée le mois volontaire il est
tout aussi insupportable et il est
d'autant plus
que en plus d'ailleurs il y a un chemin
de la reconstruction physique ça c'est
un premier point le second si vous
voulez
Gérald Darmanin a pris la parole moi
encore une fois comme vous l'avez dit de
manière très polissée parce que vous
êtes parlementaire moi je vais être un
peu moins parce que je suis avocat moi
la prise de parole du jardin je reviens
voulu qu'on n'attende pas qui est qui
est l'affaire Palmade son outil au
gouvernement depuis pas mal de temps
tant que mise à l'intérieur moi j'avais
jamais entendu parler de routière bon
donc il y a la Palmade il faut prendre
la parole on va voir ce qu'on va pouvoir
sortir
moi une mesure elle m'intéresse si je
sais qu'elle va porter un effet sur la
politique générale de sécurité routière
encore une fois je suis avocat de
victimes j'entends le message des
familles et je sais à quel point la
justice les maltraite maintenant je
pense moi avec mon passé de militant que
c'est pas parce que vous allez qualifier
domicides routier un fait que j'ai puni
par le code pénal que ça va au niveau de
l'opinion publique changer quelque chose
et modifier des comportements
par contre là où je suis convaincu c'est
que peut-être en effet que la création
de ce titre remettra en cause la vision
des magistrats et c'est peut-être là
qu'il faut travailler parce que et j'en
aurai terminé ce que me montre mon
expérience d'avocat c'est que quand vous
prenez deux familles de victimes corront
vécu la même chose le même accident qui
vont arriver devant deux tribunaux
différents avec la même peine prononcée
c'est à dire ce que le minimum syndical
de ce qu'on peut espérer dans un cas
vous allez avoir une audience où on aura
fait attention de regrouper que des
dossiers d'action de la circulation où
on aura pris soin de placer les familles
de leur donner la parole à l'audience de
faire preuve d'humanité quelque part et
dans l'autre cas vous allez arriver dans
un tribunal surchargé avec 15 20
dossiers des violences volontaires des
accidents de la circulation des vols à
l'arraché et vous allez
la victime va avoir un rôle spectateur
et bah dans un cas la victime ne sera
pas satisfaite de la peine mais sera
peut-être un peu plus soulagée et je
pense que c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
réfléchir à donner à la victime une
place qui est la sienne et après aussi
lui expliquer le sens du mot
involontaire et je pense que nous
avocats on a notre rôle si là dedans
pour préparer nos clients à ça je vous
laisse conclure les amis moi je pense
que en fait les familles elles
recherchent en fait cette véritable
prise de en considération en fait de de
ce qu'ils ont vécu de la douleur de de
la solitude
de ce manque d'accompagnement et je
pense que c'est comme ça qu'on peut
faire évoluer aussi les choses
grandement et il y a beaucoup de choses
à faire il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire et on espère que ce débat il y
aura contribué à faire parler de ce
problème et peut-être à faire évoluer
les choses merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous
[Musique]